اعداد وارقام هائله ما انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون ال الا
الله اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم فرق الانقاذ في مدينه
درنا الليبيه تواصل جهودها في البحث عن
مفقودين مدير مركز مكافحه الامراض حذر من
تلوث المياه بعد توقف محطات تحليه المياه
عن العمل في حين اكدت الامم المتحده ان
الاولويه الان لتفادي انتشار الامراض بسبب
تحلل الجثث وفي المغرب ارتفعت حصيله قتل
الزلزال الى نحو 3000 مع تواصل عمليات
البحث عن ناجين وانتشال جثامين الضحايا
كما تستمر عمليات فتح الطرق الجبليه وسط
مخاوف من الانهيارات الصخريه في وقت بدات
فيه السلطات تنفيذ المرحله الاولى من خطه
طارئه لايواء المتضررين شرطه دبي تصادر
شحنه كبتاجون تقدم در قيمتها باكثر من
مليار دولار كانت مخباه في شحنه ابواب
والواح بنا صحيفه تايمز التي ذكرت الخبر
المحت الى ان معظم الكبتاجون ينتج في
سوريا التي تعتبر اكبر مهرب للمخدرات في
العالم بحسب الصحيفه واتساب تنفي امكانيه
وضع اعلانات عبر التطبيق لزياده ايراداتها
وذلك بعدما تحدثت تقارير ان الشركه تدرس
امكانيه عرض اعلانات بالاضافه الى فرض
رسوم اشتراك لاستخدام التطبيق بدون
اعلانات ضمن سعيها لزياده الايرادات الى
اللقاء